- I'd be an ass (censor
beep) chauvinist if I say men
have more pain tolerance than women
and then I'm just saying
what everyone wants to hear
if I say women have more
pain tolerance than men,
so we'll just find out I guess won't we.
(upbeat music)
- I think I read that women are proven
to have better pain tolerance.
- In general, I feel like I've heard girls
have a higher pain tolerance than boys.
- I think girls have a higher
pain tolerance than guys do.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Three, two, one.
- Ahhhh.
- That stings.
Right off the bat stinging and hurts.
It hurts really bad.
- Oh, that hurts.
- Oh, it's cold.
- It's like crawling up my arm.
- Ahhhh, this is pleasant.
- It feels fine so far.
- This kind of just reminds me of like
being on the ice and skating
around and stuff in the winter.
- Ahhhh, ow, (censor beep) that.
I'm done, I lost, I lost.
Ow, (censor beep).
- Alright, I don't want to do it.
Ugh.
- It's very cold, ay yi yi, (panting).
- I actually keep thinking
about Titanic for some reason.
- God.
(censor beep) Is this what the people
in the Titanic felt like?
- (panting) okay.
I'm done.
(panting)
- The rest of my body is sweating.
(laughs)
- Do I even have a hand anymore?
Oh my God.
- Ohhh.
- (whimpering) I don't like it.
- If I leave my hand still
I think I'll be good.
- (censor beep) me.
- I can't do it anymore
(censor beep) ahhhhh.
- This hurts.
It's just more like it's
kind of like boring.
My hand is very numb right now though.
- Okay, now it hurts, alright.
Ahhhh, I can't move it.
- Right up to the edge there.
Alright, that's enough.
- Yes.
I felt like that way I feel
when I go on a run.
Where like it starts out really terrible
and I really don't want to be there
and then after awhile you're like
well this is just the pain I feel for now,
so I might as well just keep feeling it.
(timer dings)
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's like a nice warm bath.
- Yeah, it's great.
- Can I bring this to my desk
after we finish this video?
(laughing)
This i fun.
- Okay.
- Okay, mind over matter, calm down.
- Yeah, I'm good.
- How are you so good?
- I honestly don't know.
I did not expect this to be like this.
- (censor beep) me.
I'm just going to take
my hand out of here.
This is too (censor beep) painful.
- Do it.
- I'm ahhhhh.
- Yeah do it.
Take it out.
- Ahhh, no.
You already won so I'm taking it out.
- Alright, alright.
- Ahhh, I missed you sweet hand.
- My hand is pink.